hello and welcome to safety ridge on
sunday well it feels like a morning when
a lot of us will be talking about europe
this year's eurovision was all about
politics for the right reasons as
ukraine won a well-deserved victory in a
show of continental solidarity there
were plenty of quite unusual dues for
the uk as well but the uk the eu story
is unlikely to feel quite so generous if
westminster follows through on threats
to tear up parts of the brexit deal and
scrap elements of the northern ireland
protocol well the prime minister is
likely to strike a more conservatory
tone next week when he visits belfast to
urge the parties to get the assembly
there up and running meanwhile at home
warm words won't keep people warm as the
cost of living crisis looms large as
always over both major parties
so it's hello europe london calling with
our guests this morning
in just a moment we'll be joined by the
business secretary kwazii kwateng
and for labour we'll speak to the shadow
climate change secretary and of course
the former leader as well ed miliband
with the northern ireland assembly
gridlocked and a fresh row between the
uk and the eu brewing we'll be talking
to ireland's foreign minister simon
covney and with unions calling for mass
pay rises amid the deepening cost of
living crisis we'll also be talking to
you frances o'grady the general
secretary of the trade union congress
[Music]
good morning welcome to the program
today well labour says it will lay an
amendment to the queen's speech on
tuesday calling for a winful tax on oil
and gas companies now that's always been
opposed by my first guest the business
secretary but the chancellor has hinted
that he may go down that route there's
also talk of tax cuts as the government
struggles with the cost of living crisis
quasi quarten uh joins us now thank you
good to see you
this morning now i want to get on to the
very important business of the day first
but
later but firstly just to talk about
eurovision yeah we've come second what
is going on well we had a very good
contestant sam ryder did a good job
uh and uh he got lots of votes and it
feels right that ukraine won of course
well of course and i think the important
thing i i thought was when president
zielenski said uh that it should be
hosted as its customary in the in the
winning country and that will be ukraine
and i look forward to seeing it uh when
it's held there and they've talked about
um it being even in mario marryapol is
that something that the government in
the uk would try and support to try and
make sure that absolutely i mean uh
president zaleski was very clear that it
will be hosted in ukraine and he
mentioned mario paul and that's what we
we hope to see
and obviously the country might need
support from others to
make that dream become a reality
absolutely i mean what we've done
uh is really support ukraine uh right
through from the beginning of this
crisis
and we'll continue to do so
um now ukraine say they've succeeded in
pushing russia out of the second city
kharkiv does our own intelligence
support that well i'm not here to uh
talk about um you know what the
war situation is
um i think it's been quite encouraging
what's happened and clearly president
putin's war aims initial war aims have
been completely frustrated um but we'll
just have to see how the situation
evolves do you think it's too far to go
to say that russia could be losing at
this point no i wouldn't i wouldn't make
any uh comments on that and i'm not in a
position to do so we've got an excellent
uh defense secretary you've got
excellent uh intelligence uh and uh
those
relevant uh cabinet ministers will have
a much clearer view than i do from just
reading what i i see and and looking at
the news reports it's clear to me that
russia's ambitions their initial war
aims as i've said have been frustrated
um but there's there could be a long way
to go and they may be forced to refocus
just on the donbass region in the east
of the country yeah they've already done
that i mean it was clear that their
initial
uh ambition their initial goal was to
take kiev uh that failed uh and then
they've scaled down uh their their
target their ambition
um and as far as i can see
they haven't got their secondary aim
either but but you know it's a it's a
it's an evolving situation and we've
just heard uh just in the last few
moments from liz truss about the idea
that finland and potentially sweden
could be applying for nato membership is
that something that the uk would like to
see well i think um it's really up to
finland and sweden uh in terms of nato
membership that's something for them
they're sovereign countries
and all of nato will have to take a view
on on their application and what would
happen
well i mean you'd have to ask uh liz
trust i think she made her comments very
clearly um but we would have to just
rely on them we have to see what finnell
and sweden want to do okay before we can
make a response okay um now the prime
minister's to visit belfast this week
now that's the first visit since the
assembly elections
what will his message be
i think his message is very much that
political stability the political
stability of northern ireland
is our number one priority as far as
northern ireland is concerned
and that we should be able to
act in a sovereign way northern ireland
is as much a part of the united kingdom
as uh england cornwall the south east
and we are responsible for that as a
government and i'm sure that'll be at
the core of his message
um
just to obviously um the dp have said
that they don't want to engage in power
sharing until parts of the northern
ireland protocol are fixed in their view
and various cabinet ministers including
liz trust including dominic raav on this
program have been very clear that they
don't think the protocol is currently
working does that mean that the uk
government is prepared to unilaterally
scrap parts of that protocol even
without eu agreement absolutely right i
mean throughout this whole debate even
before
the protocol and the treaty was was
conceived we've had a number of people
in this country whose presumption has
been that the british government is
always wrong and that the eu is always
right and that's clearly too simplistic
we've tried to be uh enter into good
faith uh we've tried to negotiate we've
drawn the treaty but we've always said
even article 16 of the protocol itself
says that it can be um abrogated
unilaterally um if it's shown not to be
working and clearly
if political stability is our number one
priority and people are saying that they
won't go into power sharing if it isn't
changed we have to consider very you
know carefully how we can change it that
would break international law though
wouldn't it well i'm unclear as to this
because clearly article 16 is part of
the protocol itself and when you read i
did actually
take care to read it again just before
the program it says quite clearly that
there's a scope
to change it unilaterally unilaterally
means that we can do that ourselves
without having to reach
uh on the uh with the eu and that's
that's in the treaty the article 16 is
part of the protocol whatever happens
though there will be a response from the
eu if the uk did decide to go down this
route it could mean a trade war and
let's be clear about what that means
that means tariffs that means things
getting more expensive for people in the
middle of a cost of living crisis well
let's see what happens i think we're
getting ahead of ourselves well that's
what the eu have said and also i mean
any tariff uh situation would have to be
they have to go through arbitrators it's
not something that they can just do uh
you know willy-nilly arbitrarily
immediately uh they have to go through
uh arbitrators and you know let's let's
uh rewind a bit we got into a lot of
problems because we simply ruled out uh
the ability to walk away um article 16
is enshrined there's a reason for it it
does allow uh people to act unilaterally
and we've got ultimately to be prepared
to
to invoke it ultimately even if it could
mean things getting more expensive for
people in the uk so our number one
priority is political stability
of northern ireland now if many people
uh there uh nearly a majority are saying
that they cannot actually have a an
executive
uh without looking at the protocol again
we have to be prepared to do that we
have to do all
even if it means good it's getting more
expensive in the uk so the article 16
just
i mean that that is the logical
conclusion to what to what well i i
don't accept the premises of your
question i don't think that they're
necessarily going to be able to slap
tariffs uh arbitrarily i think it'll
take a very long time
for that process to to work out uh and
as far as i'm concerned we have
absolutely the right uh to to invoke
article 16 and to re-open or re-examine
the protocol okay um the one thing that
i really uh i guess um i'm slightly
confused about it it's pretty clear that
yourself and others in government just
don't think the protocol
is working and that's because of the
checks between
northern ireland and and great britain
um but what i don't understand is it was
boris johnson who negotiated and signed
that protocol and when he did it was
pretty clear that this is a potential
consequence of what happened i just want
to play this is quite a long clip i'm
going to play but it's from an interview
i did with boss johnson in december 2019
so just before you know that it was
signed and i do think it is worth
listening to what he said
last month you told businesses in
northern ireland that they would face no
forms no checks no barriers of any kind
under your brexit deal
and you also went on to say that if
anyone asked them to fill out a form
they should phone you up personally and
you'll direct them to throw that form in
the bin well how come then that this
government document that was leaked uh
this week
says that that's not true that there
will be checks and forms are you telling
the truth yes i am and
look at what we say in our manifesto
look what we're going to deliver the the
deal that we've done any checks no
absolutely not the deal we've done with
the eu is a brilliant deal and it allows
us to do all the things that brexit
was about so it's about taking back
control of our borders money laws but
unlike the previous arrangements it
allows the whole of the uk to come out
of the eu including northern ireland and
the only checks that there would be
would be if something was coming from gb
via northern ireland and was going on to
the republic then there might be checks
at the border into northern ireland
this document is talking about checks
both ways and that's wrong because there
won't be checks so you're saying that
this this is wrong the government's own
impact assessment is wrong your brexit
secretary is wrong all these people are
wrong and you are right yes because
because there's no question of there
being checks
on goods going uh nigb or gbni so they
don't because they're part of if you
look at what the deal is
we're part of the same customs territory
and
so pretty clear there absolutely no
checks and you said it numerous times
yeah did he not understand the deal
was he lying to me no no he fully
understood the deal but of course like
in anything
uh you have to see what the actual
practice uh was when it happened nobody
else did though because the point i make
in that interview is that the
government's impact assessment the
brexit secretary the leaked documents
all of those were saying yeah there are
going to be checks he was on his own
saying there wouldn't be i think the
prime minister
i think the prime minister was right to
say
uh that we thought it would be a much
smoother uh process that's not what he
was saying he wasn't saying there would
be light touch checks he was saying
there would be absolutely no checks and
that was wrong wasn't it well what's
happened now is i think the eu have been
unreasonable frankly
i was just reading a report that they
they won't use an i.t system uh because
uh it it breaks some of their sort of
legalist
uh way of of thinking they won't show
much flexibility and that's why we're in
the position uh we're in it's
the protocol isn't working and we have
to be prepared and it's an urgent
problem and we have to be prepared uh to
invoke our honor 16 we're in the
position we're in
because
the deal that boris johnson signed and
negotiated it was inevitable there was
going to be checks on the irish sea so
that's why i don't think it was
inevitable that uh the eu would be as
intransigent or as they have been
and it wasn't inevitable
that the people of northern ireland
would respond in the way they did to the
protocol because they've actually
experienced it and they're saying
majority the majority on the northern
ireland assembly do support the process
and they're they're they are saying
after chimpane got a majority well they
didn't get a majority they they
they didn't they were the largest party
but they were the largest parties the
majority of uh
assembly members are from parties that
so so i'm not quite sure you're right i
mean the majority of people on the on
the assembly are essentially on the
unionist side so they they broadly share
uh what the dup are things so the
majority on the assembly or from the
union so so so you're right soon faint
has the reason why shin fein are the
first minister is because they got a
plurality they got they got more seats
than anyone else but they don't have a
majority so so a lot of the people
actually uh and they've said this uh but
not everyone else has unionists there's
other there are there's an alliance
there's another you're right as well
right
champagne
and there's the alliance and then there
are the unionist uh parties which added
together and more than sdlp that's right
that's right so but but it's clear to me
that without changes to the protocol
you're not going to get um
an assembly you're not going to get an
executive okay and that's uh undermines
the fact you don't get an executive
undermines
actual stability
now labour are putting we need to uh
move on labour putting down an amendment
to the queen's speech this week calling
for a winful tax on oil and gas company
profits
will this government support that of
course not i mean it's very unusual for
any government uh to support opposition
amendments to the queen's speech so
we're going to be opposing that i just
want to try and work out where you are
on the windfall uh tax on oil and gas
companies like this is what you told me
a couple of weeks ago you're very clear
i've never been a supporter of winfield
taxes
i have been
very clear on that publicly i think it
discourages investment so that's your
position yeah why would i said that two
weeks ago two weeks ago exactly that's
exactly my position today just the
reason i'm asking is because this is
what rishi sunak said on windsville
taxes this week this is the chancellor
he said
what i want to see is significant
investment back in the uk if that
doesn't happen then no option is off the
table yeah
so who's right then
they're they're not contradictory
statements i've said personally that i'm
against them and he's the chancellor's
checker he's responsible for the budget
he's responsible for tax policy and he's
saying
that no option is off the table and in
12 years in parliament i've i've always
heard chancellors they always say no
option is off the table it would be
foolish for any chancellor to say to
rule anything in or out four months
before the budget is due so it's
entirely reasonable you don't you don't
want to see a win i wouldn't want to see
it i've always argued against it
publicly and privately but as every
chance i can remember has said four
months before the budget no option is
off the table it's entirely reasonable
okay and now there are reports in the
sunday telegraph today that cabinet
ministers are criticizing the bank of
england for failing to control inflation
one reportedly saying it has one job to
do to keep inflation at around two
percent it's hard to remember the last
time it achieved its target do you share
their frustration so it is a matter of
fact that when the bank of england
became independent in 97 as you know
they had a monetary uh target inflation
target two percent that's true and
inflation's running in almost into
double digits now
so you know that that is an issue
clearly um but i think andrew bailey's
uh doing a good job in difficult times
uh these are completely unprecedented uh
times we've had uh the the uh kovid
pandemic we've had a huge uh spike in
economic activity after the the lockdown
restrictions uh were eased and then of
course you've got this war in europe for
the first time in 70 years with tanks
rolling into uh you know european uh
territory so all of these things mean
that it's a very difficult time and i
think he's doing a reasonable job but
it's true to say that that that two
percent is part of their their mandate
they have to keep it to two percent the
inflation and they failed on that well
it's been a very difficult time to do
that i think every country in the world
pretty much is having inflation running
uh in high single digits even double
digits okay and now i want to talk to
you a little bit about some comments
made by the prime minister this week
about working from home obviously many
more people
working from home as a result of the
pandemic and saying that it makes them
more uh productive but it helps them
with flexible working as well
particularly if you've got caring
responsibilities now this is what the
prime minister said about working from
home he said my experience of working
from home is you spend an awful lot of
time making another cup of coffee and
then you know getting up
walking very slowly to the fridge
hacking off a small piece of cheese and
then walking very slowly back to your
laptop and then forgetting what it was
you're doing do you set do you share the
prime minister's assessment well look
he's making a point very vividly that
you know people's concentration his
concentration our concentration
isn't as as focused perhaps at home than
it would be at work i think that's an
entirely reasonable i think that's an
entirely reasonable thing to say many
people uh say they might work much
better in a much more focused way in the
office do you agree though with what
he's saying well i i don't know about
the details of hacking off a small piece
of cheese or anything like that do you
think that's maybe a bit more of a
reflection about how boris johnson works
i think a lot of people work from home
in that way i mean we all have our
different ways of working from home um
but and i think but i think the point
he's making is that
i think the majority actually would be
more effective
working in the office and the thing
about working in the office is not a
doctrinaire thing i think particularly
for young people if they're trying to
learn a profession or learn you know
about a business that face-to-face
contact is really important and i think
you know that's as business actually i'm
trying to encourage more people
to go back to the office and they can
share their experience with other
colleagues okay just got a couple of
things um just to finish off with
there's also been a focus on oxbridge
applications this week and whether in
the words of one cambridge professor
white private school educated boys are
the new disadvantaged candidates now
nadim zahar with the education secretary
said this week britain should be proud
of its private schools and the oxford in
cambridge shouldn't tilt the system to
accept more state school pupils
what's your position on there so i think
um nadi makes a good point i mean what
struck me about the private school
debate is that
from around the world people flock to
british private schools it's something
which brings money into the into the
country
it's something uh they're renowned
schools uh all around the world and
that's something we should be proud of i
don't see any other country if they had
those kinds of institutions they'd be
very proud of having them at the same
time
i wouldn't bash them it's not really
bashing them to say that actually this
good thing for more state school pupils
in cambridge
statistics shows that state school
pupils actually outperform their private
school peers once they make it to these
universities your old school eaten at 48
offers i know that that was half on on
previous years but there's still an
awful lot of people from the top schools
going to oxford encampment look i think
it's a very competitive uh situation
where you have to go you know to top
schools not just oxford and cambridge
you know we we tend to obsess about
cambridge we've got lots of fantastic
universities and we should have wide
access to them and i think people should
be able to
to go to them from it whatever
background they they come from uh we are
at a time and i do know i have to let
you go but very quickly neil parrish uh
the former conservative mp of course who
resigned after being caught watching
porn in the house of commons rumors he
might be standing in this by-election
i'd be very surprised if neil is
standing as an independent i mean he's
someone who's was very loyal to the path
he was an mep for many years he was an
mp for 12 years i'd be very surprised if
he did that okay thank you very much for
being on the program today mr quanting
there quasi quoting uh there
now ed miliband uh leads the charge on
getting to net zero for the labour party
but it does feel like climate change may
be slipping down the priority list as
the cost of living crisis really starts
to bite so are people in pain from
storing energy costs is going green
still a vote winner for the party and
what would it do to help those
struggling to get by well let's talk now
to labour's shadow climate change
secretary ed miliband thank you very
much for being uh with us uh you want to
put down this amendment to the queen's
speech on a windfall tax just explain
the thinking behind it
frankly we face a social emergency in
this country sophie
seven million people we know are
skipping meals because they can't afford
their bills energy bills are rocketing
upwards
and at the same time as a direct result
of that we've got oil and gas companies
making billions of pounds literally
record profits
of course the right thing to do is to
levy your windfall tax on those oil and
gas companies so we can provide proper
help to families 200 pounds across the
board cutting bills for all families 600
pounds for 9 million families who are
facing the biggest struggles and that is
absolutely essential i will say to you i
think it is frankly obscene that the
government is refusing to do this i mean
i i listened to your quasi-quitting
interview i'm not interested in their
internal machinations about this because
every day that goes by when they refuse
to do the right thing is another day
when millions of people in this country
have sleepless nights about how they're
gonna afford their bills my message to
the chancellor is this you're gonna do a
windfall tax i believe he is going to do
a win full tax because frankly it's an
unanswerable case get on with it and do
it and bring real help to families
and at the same time i just wonder um
obviously you're someone who is pushing
the climate changer agenda something
that many of our viewers will be very
concerned about as well but at a time
when bills are going up a lot of these
measures heat pumps for example costing
10 000 pounds a lot of people will be
thinking look
i love the idea of going green but right
now i simply can't afford it and what
would you say to those people
well here's the thing sophie because
this is what's changed you see the
answer to the climate crisis we face is
also the answer to the cost of living
crisis we face labor's got a plan to
insulate 19 million homes over the next
10 years 2 million in the coming year
that would cut bills cut carbon
emissions
and create jobs if you take the green
energy sprint which we need and the
government is not doing onshore wind
solar and now our cheapest forms of
power we should be driving ahead with
those things we should be getting rid of
ridiculous planning rules in england
which stop onshore win that would cut
carbon emissions and cut bills for
consumers so the old debate was shall we
go green it'll be more expensive
actually the new reality is going green
is now the cheaper option and i'm afraid
the government's half-hearted approach
to these climate issues is not just bad
for the climate and it's terrible for
the climber it's also bad when it comes
to affordability and the cost of living
crisis as well as energy security
because we can cut our gas imports too
if actually we go on this green spring
at the same time though labour's green
new deal that would cost 28 billion
pounds every year i mean that's one
percent of uk gdp and to put that in
context you know the famous windfall tax
that you talk about and every a labor
politician on the show talks about that
would raise about 2 billion pounds at
best so you would need 14 windfall taxes
to pay for one year of the green new
deal i mean is this really oh no
realistic no i'm very oh let me be very
let me very very clear about this we
think sophie that it is right to borrow
to invest that 28 billion pounds and let
me explain why
because the biggest challenge and the
big the most imprudent thing we could do
is fail to invest in tackling the
climate crisis because we will store up
massive costs for the future don't take
my word for it the office of budget
responsibility produce an excellent
report and you know i'm a bit nerdy so
i've kind of looked at their report in
detail that shows if we delay by a
decade if we delay climate action by a
decade we double the cost of going green
let me give you a very concrete example
on this just just to show you what it
means
because the government got rid of a zero
carbon home standard which would have
meant that all new homes would have been
built zero carbon we've built a million
homes since then we're going to have to
insulate retrofit those homes that's
going to cost us more money so it's
another example of why the prudent
choice the sensible economic choice the
sensible fiscal choice as well as the
ethical choice is to invest in in
tackling the climate emergency and
there's a huge potential of jobs in this
country one of which just made this
point one of one of the problems i have
with government is that they have no
plan for growth if we invest that money
in the automotive sector in electric
cars so we can get ahead in that in
steel so it can be transformed in new
industries like hydrogen it can create
good jobs at good wages the biggest
challenge we face the biggest long-term
economic challenge we face
if you were being honest with people
though wouldn't you spend a little bit
less time talking about the windfall tax
that raises two billion a year and spend
a bit more time being up front about how
the fact like as you have just been that
labour would effectively be borrowing
billions and billions more pounds every
year to pay for this 28 billion
a year green you do
i'm being i'm being i'm being extremely
open and i'm very happy to talk about
both but let me make this point to you
the reason why this matters is we have a
short-term plan and a long-term plan and
the short-term plan is really important
i do want to underline this point sophia
i was in assistance advice
uh office in my constituency on friday
meeting a couple and a single person who
are facing this cost of living christ
and let me just underline this this
point to you
these were people this was one set of
people who are homeowners and who are
deeply worried about how they'd afford
to pay their bills and another lady who
was renting our house on universal
credit incredibly worried
frankly just no hope of paying her
direct debit
this you know i know that we often talk
about emergencies and difficulties and
so on
in my 30 years or so that i've been
involved in politics i have never known
a cost of living crunch like this we're
set for the biggest fallen living
standards for 45 years in our country so
i i make no apologies for talking and
demanding demanding the government act
on the windfall tax because it is quite
wrong that they are not doing so
how concerned are you about the impact
the war in ukraine could have on energy
bills in the future
i i am concerned about it and and you
know
what this illustrates is that
if we are subject to fossil fuels if we
are reliant on fossil fuels
then we are basically at the mercy of
global events
and there's a real lesson here because
this is a fossil fuel crisis
and the best way for us to have energy
security and energy security is
incredibly important is frankly to get
off fossil fuels because the thing about
onshore wind offshore wind nuclear power
solar energy all of those things is they
are home-grown sources of power which
aren't reliant on what is happening
globally what is happening around the
world and so that's why it's so
important that we that we um
that we go on this green energy sprint
okay um now just talking about ukraine
um you know the atrocities that vladimir
putin's committed in ukraine were in
many ways foreshadowed
by what russia did in syria you know
it's part of the same playbook mario
poll seemingly like another aleppo the
general known as the butcher of syria
now leading the war effort in ukraine
do you regret voting against military
action in syria back in 2013.
no no i don't uh sophie look what i was
presented with when it came to what was
happening uh in syria
was a proposition
where we would not have been getting rid
of all the chemical weapons but this was
about the chemical weapons attack
that president assad had made we would
not be getting rid of all his chemical
weapons and there was no proper plan for
how we would be using british troops and
where this where our intervention would
go and we made a vow after iraq which
was that if we committed british troops
we would do so clear about our
objectives with a clear sense of a plan
and a clear sense that that plan would
be successful and our argument to david
cameron was
set out a clear plan how this is going
to work and what is going to mean and
those who say well it would have changed
the course of the war president trump
did actually bomb president assad in
relation to a chemical weapons attack a
few years later and it did not change
the course of the war so so of course
what has happened in syria is an
appalling tragedy but the idea that us
getting involved in another war in the
middle east would have stopped it
happening i just don't buy i'm afraid
i understand about your concerns about
not having a proper strategy um at the
time but was it also about sending a
message to people around the world that
if you commit war crimes and the west
will
act and by not doing anything then you
also sent a message to people like putin
that the west wouldn't necessarily act
you know i remember in the election
campaign when you were a leader that
sort of famous moment when you spoke to
jeremy paxman you said hell yes i'm
tough enough talking about refusing to
back the airstrikes in syria that barack
obama wanted you said standing up to the
leader of the free world shows a certain
toughness i would say
do you think the real toughness comes
from standing up to leaders of the
unfree world
i just want to say you said at the
beginning of that question should we not
have engaged in military action in order
to send a message
i think we should learn some lessons
from our past on this
because
when terrible things happen around the
world yes we have a responsibility uh to
act in concert with our allies and we
are acting in relation to ukraine and
with the toughest economic sanctions
providing defensive equipment rightly to
the ukrainian regime against the
appalling acts of putin
but
when we commit british troops we don't
just do so to send a message we are
putting the young men and women of our
country in harm's way
and i think that leaders have a deep
responsibility to know that they are
doing so on the basis that we have a
chance of it succeeding we have a clear
plan
and we know where where this where the
intervention is going to go so and you
know in relation to libya i supported
david cameron in relation to
intervention uh in libya because i
thought there was a plan in relation to
the kind of humanitarian emergency that
there was there but i took my
responsibility
incredibly seriously as somebody who
wanted to be the prime minister of the
country that if i was going to commit
british troops it was on the right basis
in the right way
and with a clear chance of success
okay
um now moving on to a few other issues
in the news recently sadiq khan the
mayor of london has set up a commission
to look into the potential legalization
of cannabis
would you like to see cannabis legalized
that isn't labour's position no
uh what what what we've said and look we
welcome sadiq looking at these issues
because this debate uh carry carries on
and should carry on he's looking at a
whole range of issues under i think it's
lord faulkner a distinguished person
very wise person on these issues
to look at issues of treatment and
education
and the wider issues that you mentioned
but look labour isn't convinced
well look you know i've said in the past
that there's something this is something
that needs to be looked at you i think
you probably uh uh know that but
labour's had a cabinet position which is
a position i support as a member of the
shadow cabinet is to say that we're not
yet convinced of the case uh for moving
on decriminalization but obviously we'll
look at what lord faulkner's commission
has to say
okay and now we had the local elections
two weeks ago and i think it is fair to
say of course that kids dahmer made
progress compared to the jeremy corbyn
position
would you say he's now stuck in uh ed
miliband territory
i'm not i don't i don't think you mean
that as a compliment sophie so maybe i
should say no um look i think what um i
think what keir is doing is that we had
a terrible defeat in 2019
he has done a remarkable job i think in
bringing the party back from the brink
from what happened in 2019 putting us
back on the pitch let me tell you what i
detected as i went around the country in
the local elections
i think there is a big mood for change
in this country not just the cost of
living crisis this goes back much
further to brexit to the financial
crisis people feel the country's not
working for them now i think people are
increasingly convinced that the tories
aren't going to deliver and i have to
say listening to that quasi quieting
interview it's no wonder people think
the tories can't deliver our job is to
show that we can bring that change and
that is a work in progress of course it
is we've got really important ideas like
the windfall tax like the climate
investment pledge and what you're going
to see and what i know kiera's
determined to do is to show that burning
passion and that set of proposals to
change our country to bring the change
that i think people are crying out for
in this country you know remember after
the pandemic or during the pandemic
sophie we said we would build back
better all of us across politics
actually at the moment we're set to
build back far worse under this
government so we've got to show that we
can bring the change we need and i'm
convinced we can
okay thank you for taking that with uh
customary good humor it's appreciated
just finally before i let you go and
it's fair to say i think his time was
going through one of the more difficult
periods of his leadership have you
offered him any advice on it
i think all periods for um at the leader
of the opposition are challenging at
least in my experience sophie as you
know you were with me in the campaign of
2015 he doesn't need my advice you know
i think the thing about kier is that the
more people get to know him the more
they like what they see he's somebody of
great decency great integrity somebody
who cares deeply about this country what
what what drives kiev stammer in my view
what drives him is this country doesn't
work for millions of people across our
land this economy doesn't work for
millions of people across our country
and actually what his burning passion is
to change that economy to deliver good
jobs at decent wages to restore our
public services and to tackle the
climate crisis and create those good
jobs i was talking about and you know
the whole of the labour party is united
behind him in that mission
okay thank you uh very much uh indeed ed
miliband uh there thank you thank you
now as we uh mentioned earlier in the
program the prime minister's going to
belfast this week to urge the parties
there to come to an agreement and get
the power sharing institutions back up
and running the assembly is currently
gridlocked because the dep won't take
part until the northern ireland protocol
is changed or dropped now that of course
is likely to spark an almighty row with
the eu and some countries have already
threatened a trade war if the uk acts
unilaterally well let's go live to cork
now we can talk to ireland's foreign and
defense minister simon covney thank you
very much for being with us this morning
and now you've written in the sunday
telegraph today to say i'm deeply
concerned for the well-being of the
partnership between our countries can
you just explain your concerns
well first of all just to correct
something that you've said the eu hasn't
threatened anything not a trade war and
not anything else what the eu wants is
partnership
so that we can work together to resolve
the issues that remain in relation to
the protocol which of course was
designed to try to manage the disruption
of brexit on the island of ireland
so the last thing the eu wants the last
thing that ireland wants
is tension with the uk particularly at
the moment given the
uh what's happening in ukraine russian
aggression and the need to work together
on an international stage
but unfortunately it has been the
briefings that has come from the british
government this week
that has raised a real red flag in
dublin and in brussels
because the british government is now
threatening to break international law
to break a treaty that they signed with
the eu and that they designed with the
eu
and ratified with a huge majority in the
house of commons
and in doing so uh potentially creating
huge problems on the island of ireland
and while there are issues that need to
be resolved in relation to the
implementation of the protocol there are
concerns within the unionist community
in particular that need a comprehensive
response the way to do that isn't for
the british government to act
unilaterally
and to brief against the eu in the way
that they have this week encouraging the
prime minister to to act like he's acted
on ukraine in relation to um the
protocol
and urging him to rip it up
that kind of aggressive language does
nothing uh to move us forward on what is
a difficult issue you and i have spoken
about the fallout from brexit on the
island of ireland before we've just had
an election in northern ireland which
was a difficult election it was a
polarizing election
and the challenge for us all is to
listen to all communities unionists and
nationalists and people who don't
describe themselves as either
and try to ensure that the agreements
that we've signed in the past which is
now international law
is applied with the flexibility and the
pragmatism to respond to all of those
concerns as opposed to
legislating unilaterally uh for the
concerns of one community in northern
ireland which it seems to me is what the
british government is now uh
saying that they will do as soon as this
week
if the eu doesn't give them everything
they want so that is not the way to
approach a problem with a neighbor with
a friend and with allies and partners
which is what the uk has right across
the european union right now
you saying that um
about boris johnson shouldn't take the
same approach with the protocol as he
did with ukraine what exactly did you
mean by that well what i mean by that is
that lord frost who of course was the
the former negotiator on brexit issues
who was
one of the architects of the northern
ireland protocol and the withdrawal
agreement which allowed the uk to leave
the eu in a structured and managed way
and he did a good job in many ways for
the uk
but he on the front of the telegraph
this week
urging the prime minister to show the
leadership that he's shown in ukraine
and to rip up the northern ireland
protocol i mean what we are getting
there is a senior figure in the
conservative party calling on his prime
minister to break international law and
to create huge problems uh for britain's
neighbor here in ireland
and of course unnecessary tension with
the eu at a time when we all need to be
working together to solve problems not
least of course in ukraine
there are almost 30 000 ukrainians have
come to ireland so far seeking refuge
and safety from uh from the war in
ukraine five and a half million
across the eu
and we have huge challenges to overcome
together the idea that we would ratchet
up the tension on something else an
issue that we've been dealing with now
for six years which is the decision of
the people of the united kingdom to
leave the european union and all that
flows from that in terms of disruption
and tension
uh that we would ratchet that up now to
to new heights is deeply unhelpful
particularly when the eu
wants to actually continue to negotiate
wants to show
flexibility at once to compromise to
actually recognize that there are
legitimate concerns held within the
unionist community in northern ireland
that need a comprehensive response the
primary one being that we need to treat
goods that are staying in northern
ireland differently to goods that are at
risk of traveling on through northern
ireland into the eu and the eu single
market and the eu is willing to do that
and dramatically change the number of
checks on those goods if they can find a
partner in london to do it with them so
at least trust the foreign secretary uh
says the current eu proposals fail to
properly address the real issues
affecting northern ireland and in some
cases would take us backwards and if you
look at what some of what the uk wants
you know as you're talking about there
changing the burden of proof for goods
remaining in northern ireland expanding
the trusted trader policy simplifying
the process so traders have to provide
less information perhaps action on grace
periods and vat
can you understand from the frustration
in westminster that they believe that
the eu has been heavy-handed in imposing
some of these checks in a very very
delicate as you know of course uh border
in the irish sea uh the dep currently
refusing to set up a power sharing
arrangement in northern ireland so time
really is of the essence can you
understand some of the frustration in
the in westminster at
what they would perceive as a reluctance
from the eu to act decisively or quickly
enough
so they can i tell you i've been in
these discussions for more than five
years now uh i have been uh in
negotiations with i think four or five
different brexit ministers
on behalf of the british government and
all good people
um but let me tell you ireland is also
frustrated we are dealing with the
consequences now of a decision by the
british people on our own country that's
cost us hundreds of millions of euros
that is risking the peace process and
its institutions on the island of
ireland
and so you know when we focus on
frustrations
uh we need to think beyond westminster
yes of course liz trust and she's a good
person and i know her well
she wants to see changes in terms of how
the protocol is implemented and she is
perfectly entitled to seek those changes
she has a partner in mar sefkovic who's
the vice president of the european
commission who wants to do that with her
but there's no way the eu can compromise
if the if the uk is threatening
unilateral action to pass domestic
legislation to set aside international
obligations under an international
treaty that don't forget the uk was the
primary designer of along with with the
eu so yes i understand the frustrations
and in particular i understand the
frustrations in the unionist community
i've spoken to many unionists who want
to see pragmatism and real flexibility
so the trade within the united kingdom
in other words trade between great
britain and northern ireland
uh is not disrupted in any way that is
not absolutely necessary and we can get
there to a landing zone if we work in
partnership but you know saber rattling
and grandstanding um
in westminster ratcheting up tension is
not the way to do it uh and what i am
saying and i've invited uh uh liz trust
to to come to dublin to talk to me in
detail about those concerns i've offered
to come to london in fact i've come to
london many times on these issues i
think mario stefanovic is in the same
position but look at a time when the
world needs the western world to be
united uh to be acting in concert
to solve problems together
this is a problem we need to solve
together the last thing ireland wants
the last thing the eu needs is tension
with a country the size and the
influence of the united kingdom so let's
work together through the summer get
these issues resolved get the
institutions back up and running in
northern ireland which is
the northern ireland one the final thing
i'd say is sophie that um you know there
is an impression often across the united
kingdom that northern ireland is deeply
unhappy with the protocol and that a
majority of people want to change that
is simply not true the majority of
people in northern ireland have just
voted for candidates that actually are
in favor of the protocol because of how
it manages the disruption of brexit 53
out of the 90 mlas that were elected in
northern ireland would vote in favor of
the protocol tomorrow if asked to do so
what they want
is pragmatism and flexibility in terms
of how it's implemented that's what the
eu wants to offer that's what dublin
wants to help facilitate and i hope
that's what the british government will
work with us on in the weeks ahead yeah
which is the point that i made to quasi
quartering about the majority on the
north aligned assembly i just wanted to
quickly come back on you said there that
you had sent an invitation to liz trust
to meet has she responded to that
invitation
well look i mean we're we're talking
again on monday evening um i mean you
know i know liz trust very well we we
shared other briefs uh that were similar
in the irish and british governments in
the past we'll speak again on monday um
you know this is such an important issue
for ireland that i am available at short
notice to come to london or anywhere
else quite frankly to try and work
through these
issues you picking up are you picking up
any difference in tone between liz truss
who some say in the press briefings here
is more strident and the prime minister
who it's briefed is more conciliatory in
his tone is is there a split there from
what you what you sense
well look you know i i want to be
careful not to comment on
the approach of british politics between
number 10 and and others in cabinet you
know all i can say is there is a landing
zone and a solution that we can get to
here if there is
a real partnership in terms of trying to
solve these problems um some of what's
been said this week
by various members of the british
cabinet is unhelpful in terms of helping
us to get there but there is an
opportunity i hope in the next few days
to get this dialogue back on track and
to avoid
uh the the creation of a lot of
unnecessary tension uh by by publishing
uh unilateral legislation that would
uh send headlines around the world
that the united kingdom is deliberately
breaking international law and creating
huge tension with their closest
neighbors and potentially undermining a
peace process by doing that and it's not
the uk government
if the uk did act unilaterally
um without the agreement of the eu i'm
interested to know how the eu would
respond would you take legal action
could we see the imposition
of tariffs as a result
well i mean the eu has already
taken legal action because the protocol
isn't being implemented and the uk has
decided unilaterally to put in place
grace periods and so on but the eu in an
effort to try to build partnership set
aside that legal action they've frozen
it uh in an effort to try to negotiate a
sensible way forward and you know
if ever if ever that's an indication of
where the eu is on this space you know
people need to look at that the eu isn't
threatening anything and i think for us
to focus on how the eu would respond to
the british government deliberately
breaching international law is probably
where we shouldn't be right now instead
we need to be trying to avoid that
situation but i think everybody
understands uh if the uh if the british
government decides to set aside
international law to create significant
uncertainty on the island of ireland in
terms of single market membership and a
whole range of other things well then of
course there's a consequence the eu is
forced to respond but that is not where
we want to be where we want to be is
good neighbors good friends and solving
problems together and i would encourage
the influencers within the british
government to ensure that that's the
course that they decided you would be
forced to respond but i'm still just
unclear on what what that response would
be would it be yes i don't think you are
unclear actually but i i'm not here this
morning to talk about understanding um
the ratcheting up of tension i'm here
this morning to try to find solutions
and that's where i hope the british
government will be this week as well and
just very finally you know as you say
you know we have spoken
numerous times over the last few years
on brexit related
it does strike me this morning that you
do seem particularly frustrated i guess
as a word perhaps even even angry would
that be a fair summary of where your
head is at right now well i mean i think
you know if you look at the comments
that i've made this week at the comments
that the t-shirt has made this week you
know we are both
friends of britain you know um
england and britain have shaped who i am
who many in the irish cabinet are you
know many of my family are
our british citizens um some of my
family work and employ a lot of people
across the uk i've been to university in
england there isn't an anti-british bone
in my body quite the opposite but what i
see at the moment is a british
government
making statements briefing against the
eu
and creating a lot of tension in my
country your closest neighbor and also
potentially uh being on the verge of
making a decision that could
fundamentally undermine the functioning
of the institutions of the peace process
in northern ireland let's not forget
this is not only about unionism of
course it needs to be partly about union
unionism but a majority of people in
northern ireland voted against brexit
and would vote against brexit again in
the morning if it was put to them a
majority of people in northern ireland
are in favor of the protocol because
they see that it does a reasonable job
to manage the disruption of brexit in in
the irish circumstances there is a
minority a large minority within
unionism who are unhappy with the
protocol there are solutions that we can
put in place that can ease that concern
and that's what we need to focus on
doing together as opposed to the british
government acting on its own illegally
in a way that doesn't reflect majority
opinion in northern ireland and perhaps
most importantly sends a message to the
world that this british government when
it suits them will set aside
international law i don't say things
like that lightly i mean my job is to be
a diplomat i'm a foreign minister i'm a
defense minister and i want a really
good relationship with my closest
neighbor
but what's happening at the moment has
forced ireland into taking a much more
strident position
uh and responding honestly uh to the
uh unhelpful briefings that we're
getting from very very senior levels
within the british government this week
which seems to be laying the groundwork
for a decision which i believe could be
deeply harmful for the relationship
between britain and ireland uh if we
don't see sense in the next few days
okay simon coveney thank you very much
for being on the program this morning
now the trade union congress is going to
hold a rally in london next month
calling for mass pay rises for workers
because of the cost of living crisis now
there were hints this week that the
government could do more possibly tax
cuts even the emergency budget that
labour's been calling for but if there
isn't more action could the unions be
squaring up for a summer of strikes well
we're joined now by the general
secretary of the tuc francis o'grady
thank you so much for being with us
how worried are you about the rising
cost of living and what that means for
low-paid workers in particular
i think everybody's worried they're
seeing
those price increases eating to pay
packets but also into
pensions and benefits and i think
there's a real sense that
the government needs to get on with this
now you know we know that millions of
working families are struggling we're
seeing the number of children in
absolute poverty increase
electricity and gas bills rising at ten
times the rate of wages it's about time
that the government recognizes a living
standards emergency and they need to
come back to parliament with an
emergency budget i mean frankly there's
so much talk on the conservative back
benches that we're going to see another
u-turn on this i wish the government
would just get on with it
you i want to see more rises in people's
pay to help them at a time of course
when the cost of living is increasing
but is there a concern that that could
further stoke inflation andrew bailey
the governor of the bank of england has
said you know we do need to see a
moderation of wage rises and i don't
want to sugarcoat that it's painful but
we need to see that in order to get
through this problem more quickly do you
agree with that
england was wrong on this one the
governor was wrong uh all the evidence
is that prices are being driven by
increases in energy prices certainly not
wages which are set to fall in real
terms on the contrary people need help
now
and in addition if we suck demand out of
the economy then we're going to risk
that recession uh coming ever sooner so
what we need is for the chancellor who
i'm afraid woefully failed working
families with his spring statement and i
think
most people recognize that he needs to
come back with that winful tax on the
energy companies that would provide some
immediate relief a real investment in
renewables so we tackle the root causes
of the problems with high energy prices
a boost in the minimum wage how on earth
people are supposed to survive on nine
pounds 50 an hour when in real terms of
course that's set to fall we need a a
real boost the minimum wage and fair pay
agreements across the board and and the
chancellor you know we've had enough of
lessons from conservative mps on
uh cooking or buying value brands i
think
they are looking you know incredibly out
of touch with what most people are
experiencing people on low incomes are
very good at managing their budgets the
problem is those budgets are too tight
and of course it's bad for the country
too we've we've seen this government
fail to bring in an employment rights
bill to tackle low pay and insecurity
and that is costing the exchequer to the
tune of 10 billion pounds
in lost tax revenue and higher benefit
payouts it's bad economics it's a false
economy and working and expect
governments to stand up for them and
help them now not in a few months time
when it's too late
over the last 12 months the tec has
logged 300 disputes in different
industries which effectively illustrates
that people are challenging below
inflation pay rises
do you think we could see widespread
industrial action if more isn't done on
pay
look i think the government needs to
start listening to people and get back
in touch with the strength of feeling on
this um yes of course unions exist to
try it and get better and fairer pay
deals and
terms and conditions for their members
that's what they do and we have seen
that mood increasing in both the public
and the private sector
but um of course we've got that national
demonstration on saturday the 8th the
18th of june where working people will
be coming together to protest and
demanding better but you know the way to
deal with this is for
the chancellor to get a move on come
back to parliament with that emergency
budget for employers to get around the
table with unions to negotiate fair
solutions we've seen profits recover
very well by the way i think um the
governor did belatedly acknowledge that
that was the case um and we just need a
bit of fair treatment you know we we all
want more money for our public services
we all want the uh country's finances to
be in good health but it's a case of
fairness here and i think people feel
very strongly
that uh the wealthy are not paying their
fair share of tax
that workers are being treated like a
cash machine hammered every time there's
a crisis we've had 10 years of this
don't forget over 10 years of austerity
pay freezes real pay cuts and there's
there's no more fat left to trim
people are looking for help now
at the same time you know you mentioned
there there the rally coming up and
ahead of that rally your colleague dave
ward the general secretary of the
communication workers union has said
employers are out of control
i mean most employers are businesses who
are also struggling with the rising cost
of living aren't they like the rising
cost of of everything from energy bills
to to products and supply of the supply
side they're providing jobs for millions
of people is that really the kind of
language that is helpful
look i think there's clearly a mixed
picture
you know we have some very good
agreements with employers and we've made
some very good um pay settlements but
we've also got employers who were
hoarding cash who were paying fairly um
i i think most people would agree
obscene increases in top pay in the
boardroom
and you know as i say people just want
to see a bit of fairness but i think the
government can't walk away from this it
i think most people agree that that
spring statement which included tax
hikes uh which hit the lowest paid and
young workers hardest on national
insurance you know simply wasn't fair
they need to come back with an emergency
budget but rather than spinning it out
to the
summer or august as we're hearing in
some newspapers they need to come back
and do it now there are some ready-made
solutions that make sense including that
whimple tax on uh energy companies and
let's not forget that the oil companies
said it would make no difference at all
to their plans for investment they can
afford it
um and they should do it and the
government should get on with it now i
do want to ask you about the prime
minister's comments about working from
home i asked quasi classic about them
early he said that he thought that
actually for some people it did reflect
their experience
the prime minister said my experience of
working from home is that you spend an
awful lot of time making another cup of
coffee and then you know getting up
walking slowly to the fridge hacking off
a small piece of cheese and then walking
very slowly back to your laptop and
forgetting what it was you were doing
do you think he's right
well it feels a bit ironic given i guess
the prime minister is the classic case
of somebody who always works from home
because he's based in number 10 and that
may be his experience
of grabbing coffees and wandering around
the kitchen but i think again people
deserve a bit of basic respect i think
people who work from home work very hard
and this should be a matter you know for
uh unions and employers to
sit down and come up with sensible
agreements i i would have hoped that
politicians facing a living standards
emergency had more important things to
be getting on with than trying to
interfere in day-to-day industrial
relations between civil servants
managers and their unions
um this week the government also
announced 90 000 job losses among civil
servants i think it's important to say
you know we're not just talking about
what the newspapers would call sort of
pen pushers
these are prison officers court staff
customs officers
immigration case handlers
are you worried that this is going to
damage public services and specifically
in what ways
well of course this this is you know
back to austerity and we saw how
austerity
failed not only ordinary people and
families but it failed uh the country in
the end by holding back growth
and of course you know these these are
key workers who work right through the
crisis
uh important uh public services for all
of us that provide that safety net
uh that keep us safe
you know these are important jobs so how
on earth the government expects to be
able to shed 90 000 at a stroke and for
it not to
damage
communities in the country i i really
don't know so i think we need to
hear from them exactly what their plans
are but don't be surprised
that unions are angry and that
communities
will be extremely angry if we're looking
to get hit again in terms of key public
services that keep us safe
and just finally um you are stepping
down at the end of the year after a
decade as the first woman to hold the
job of tuc
general secretary and i've spoken to you
many times you know over that period and
i'm just wondering
you know if there's any kind of
reflections you would give on that
decade in the job you know do you think
workers are better off now or when you
started and also what has it been like
for being
like a woman you know in the world of
work right at that moment and at a time
when obviously more recently there's
been lots of debate about women in the
workplace as well
well i'm gonna be keeping my shoulders
to the wheel for some time yeah i don't
leave until the end of december and i'm
focused absolutely on you know doing our
bit
uh to ensure that the government and
employers
face head on this living standards
crisis and give working people a fair
deal
but i am proud of what we've achieved
and i think the real lesson is that when
we work together as a trade union
movement we can achieve a lot if you
think about the pandemic our wonderful
uh members in health social care
transport
refuse collection right across the piece
but so often they had to look to unions
to protect their health and safety they
didn't have proper ppe
we had to fight for the national
guidelines
and of course the furlough scheme
wouldn't have happened without the trade
union movement and you know ultimately
protected 12 million livelihoods at its
peak and
you know that
was designed to help the economy recover
more quickly too but you know to do that
in a way that channeled support through
people's pay packets is the best way to
sustain
demands in in local economies shops and
businesses so
you know i think we've got a lot to be
proud of on the equality front um you
know we are now a movement 50 50 men and
women
we reflect
all society and every race every village
and every background and i'm proud of
that too because i think when working
people
stand together when we're united we can
win
okay thank you so much for being on the
program always interesting to talk fans
are so great you there
thank you
now just before we go a quick reminder
that our weekly podcast is available
every week since it's a weekly podcast
no surprise there are highlights of the
interviews and thoughts from the team on
the pod and you can find it wherever you
usually get your podcasts just search
for safety ridge on sunday
and then it should be there
well that is it for this week's slogan
sunday in a moment after the break we're
going to be running through today's
interviews seeing what we learned and
we'll be joined by our deputy political
editor sam coats thank you very much for
joining us this sunday morning see you
next week
[Music]
hello and welcome to safety ridge the
take where we take a pause and reflect
on what we've just been hearing over the
last hour i spoke to the business
secretary kwazii kwateng the shadow
climate change secretary ed miliband and
ireland's foreign minister simon
coughley so pretty backed show now as
always our deputy political editor sam
coats is on hand to help us analyze this
morning's interviews um sam i have to
just
pause for a moment you appear to be in
some kind of game of thrones dungeon
what's going on
well you heard in your show uh sophie
that uh question was echoing the words
of the prime minister that they think
it's reasonable to ask people to go back
to the office because you never quite
know
what happens when you let people work
from home or indeed even where they are
yes this is the safer ridge that takes
sunday summer road show we're touring
the country uh some of the less known
spots uh in order to bring you the take
from perhaps different perspectives than
you might have otherwise got so i hope
you've got the hunk of cheese in the
fridge just off camera
i have
and
i have to say though
this is
not
working from home uh looks like for most
people that was a key part of the show
but also today what was interesting uh
was
we were getting back into the
nitty-gritty of perhaps more traditional
politics of after weeks of local
elections and uh interestingly
fascinatingly no mention uh in your show
really of partygate uh finds on either
side really
but what there was uh was uh raising up
the flagpole of the issue of northern
ireland now like most of the nation i
was watching the eurovision song contest
last night it appears that britain is
more popular than some people would
suggest it came second to ukraine in the
eurovision song contest uh but could
britain's popularity on the world stage
be about to take a knock that was pretty
much the number one issue this morning
yeah certainly so we'll come back to you
in just a moment but let's hear a bit
from uh some of those uh interviews that
sam was talking about and i do think sam
is got a point there when he talks about
you know british popularity perhaps
riding high after what's seen as a very
successful
intervention in ukraine being a key ally
there of president zelinski but
what is clearly brewing is an almighty
route with the european union i have to
say that there was some conservatory
messages in the newspapers this morning
but the business secretary quasi quite
saying i thought was pretty strong when
he was talking
about the fact that he believes that the
uk should be able to take unilateral
action when it comes to the northern
ireland protocol he said the uk reserves
the right to act unilaterally let's have
a little listen to what he said
it says quite clearly that there's a
scope
to change it unilaterally unilaterally
means that we can do that ourselves
without having to reach agreement uh on
the uh with the eu and that's that's in
the treaty the article 16 is part of the
protocol i don't think that they're
necessarily going to be able to slap
tariffs uh arbitrarily i think it'll
take a very long time for that process
to work out
and as far as i'm concerned we have
absolutely the right uh to to invoke
article 16 and to re-open or re-examine
the protocol
absolutely the right to uh invoke
article 16. i wonder if we're starting
to get a little bit of a direction of
travel being fleshed out there by quasi
quieting um we also talked on the
program to the irish foreign minister
simon covney he had a very different
perspective on this he said the issues
could be solved he talked a lot about a
potential landing ground between the uk
and the eu when it came comes to the
protocol in northern ireland and he was
very careful i thought to say that he
understood
some of the concerns particularly from
unionists in the northern ireland
assembly talking about the dep
of course who are very worried about the
implementation of that protocol
but talking also very firmly about what
he described as sabre rattling and
grandstanding by the uk government and
how in his view it was unhelpful
we need to think beyond westminster yes
of course liz trusted she's a good
person and i know her well
uh she wants to see changes in terms of
how the protocol is implemented and she
is perfectly entitled to seek those
changes she has a partner in mar
sefkovic who's the vice president of the
european commission who wants to do that
with her
but there's no way the eu can compromise
if the if the uk is threatening
unilateral action to pass domestic
legislation to set aside international
obligations under an international
treaty that don't forget the uk was the
primary designer of along with with the
eu so yes i understand the frustrations
and in particular i understand the
frustrations in the unionist community
i've spoken to many unionists who want
to see pragmatism and real flexibility
so the trade within the united kingdom
in other words trade between great
britain and northern ireland
uh is not disrupted in any way that is
not absolutely necessary and we can get
there to a landing zone if we work in
partnership but you know saber rattling
and grandstanding um
in westminster ratcheting up tension is
not the way to do it
uh there you go there uh pretty strong
words i thought actually this morning
from simon caveney as well let's talk
now to our participator
sam coates and bring you back in
simon covenant was very careful there to
talk up the idea of a landing zone uh
potentially being reached you said he
was talking about ignoring the uh what
he described as grandstanding and saying
it was unhelpful
what's your sense from you know talking
to the people involved in this do you
think a landing zone is possible
well let's start with what we know
sophie we know it's going to be a very
big week involving northern ireland the
prime minister goes there tomorrow there
could then be announcement on tuesday
about perhaps the kind of legislation
that the government is thinking of
bringing in
that would essentially disapply that
would
mean that we didn't have to implement
parts of the brexit deal relating to
northern ireland that boris johnson
signed up to in 2019
but let's be honest sophie what you've
been hearing over the last few days in
public and i've been hearing in private
is uh disagreements disagreements on
emphasis perhaps even disagreements on
tactics is the government uh primarily
looking to use a piece of legislation a
new law uh to try and set aside
legislation northern ireland sort out
the northern ireland protocol or could
it pull the emergency lever that was
already built into the treaties known as
article 16 that allows the uk to
disapply uh unilaterally some of the
things that uh have to be done at the
moment in northern ireland quasi-quating
business secretary talking that up on
your program so quite how they're going
to do it uh seems well different people
have been saying different things but
the big point sophie i think
is i am unclear what the government goal
is
is the government goal
to try and get a series of changes
specific policy goals and we know what
they are uh they're to reduce the number
of checks uh on goods going from great
britain to northern ireland
it's to try and make sure that as new eu
law on goods comes in for the rest of
the block that isn't uh applied in
northern ireland it's to reduce or
eliminate the role of the european court
of justice now those are the sort of
aims that the uk government wants to
negotiate possibly uh with a gun in its
hand uh with the european union so is
that the goal or is the goal much more
political because the other thing that
the government have said is that the
goal is to use these changes to try and
restart power sharing effectively
allowing jeffrey donaldson's dup to
decide whether or not
he's going to go back into the stormont
assembly he's going to go back into
government based on the changes that the
government are either seeking or secure
because if your goal is a series of
policy measures then that might be
achievable if your goal is everything
that the dep has been asking for in
public to date then that might be just
quite a lot harder and i think that that
my lack of understanding of which of the
two goals it is that dissonance between
different parts of government all
reflects different people inside the
cabinet having different views on
exactly that question and has led to
some pretty ugly briefing you'll have
seen the word knuckleheads being used by
some who want to go a bit softer against
some who meant to go a bit harder
possibly those around liz trust i've
heard that briefing too it's not very
pretty and that's not particularly
reassuring when people are odds at the
heart of government going into what's
likely to be quite a fraught
few days and weeks on perhaps britain's
most constitutional issue yeah i think
that's certainly i can't really be
plunged back into these kind of brexit
weeds again but we have been sam thank
you very much indeed really important uh
decisions to be made in the coming days
and weeks on brexit and of course it's
worth noting that we still don't have a
fully functioning northern ireland
assembly until
that is sorted out we'll have more from
sam as we get to his take on this
morning interviews and we'll hear a bit
more from our guests
[Music]
hello welcome back to sophie john sunday
the take where we take you back through
the morning's interviews with some
analysis from me and also our deputy
political editor sam coates
now one of the big debates in politics
at the moment is whether there should be
a windfall tax on oil and gas companies
in order to help pay for some of the
increasing cost of living for uh
families now the two main parties
currently disagree uh on what should be
done uh i asked her quasi-quatting about
it he of course is the business
secretary just two weeks ago he told me
that he was against uh the idea of a
winful tax because he was worried that
it would deter
investment so i was trying to get to the
bottom
of whether or not that was still his
position
i've said personally that i'm against
them and he's the chancellor checker
he's responsible for the budget he's
responsible for tax policy and he's
saying
that no option is off the table and in
12 years in parliament i've i've always
heard chances they always say no option
is off the table it would be foolish for
any chancellor to say to rule anything
in or out four months before the budget
is due so it's entirely reasonable you
don't you don't want to see a win i
wouldn't want to see it i've always
argued against it publicly and privately
but as every chance i can remember has
said four months before the budget no
option is off the table it's entirely
reasonable
the right thing to do is to levy a
windfall tax on those oil and gas
companies so we can provide proper help
to families 200 pounds across the board
cutting bills for all families 600
pounds for 9 million families who are
facing the biggest struggles and that is
absolutely essential i will say to you i
think it is frankly obscene that the
government is refusing to do this i mean
i i listened to your quasi-quitting
interview i'm not interested in their
internal machinations about this because
every day that goes by when they refuse
to do the right thing is another day
when millions of people in this country
have sleepless nights about how they're
going to afford their bills my message
to the chancellor is this you're going
to do a win full tax i believe he is
going to do a win full tax because
frankly it's an unanswerable case get on
with it and do it and bring real help to
families
ed miliband thinks the chancellor is
going to do a winful tax it's pretty
clear quasi quantang is still
holding out hope that he won't let's try
and find out what our deputy political
editor thinks at sam's on hand again
um it's one of those issues where it
feels like you know every week we talk
about her windfall attacks but it is
because there does seem to be this
little bit of wiggle room for the
government
uh
with the chancellor leaving the door
open to imposing one
that's right sophie i think very
specifically in the treasury in the
political end of the treasury it felt
like there was a bit of a shift this
week
where the kind of language being used uh
about a windville tax seemed to change
it seemed to become a bit more receptive
and i think part of that is because when
you look at the comments by the chief
executive of bp
the former chief executive of bp lord
brown um all suggesting that actually a
windfall tax would be a perfectly valid
policy tool for a government to use
given that these companies are making
way way higher bigger profits than
they're expecting because the global
price of energy has gone up because of
the conflict in ukraine because of all
of that some in government believe it's
virtually like companies like bp are
campaigning for a windfall
tax
even though it would be against the
interests of their
shareholders and because of that and
because of the pressure that you just
heard from labour it does
seem to be
at least back on uh the long list of
government policy options interesting
from question there not only was he
inhabiting
the political space that he thinks it's
completely normal for a cabinet minister
to come on sunday morning shows and
campaign against a policy option uh
that's yet to be determined by
government and cabinet uh when uh uh the
chancellor said pretty much the direct
or the chances team have said the direct
opposite uh uh just uh the week uh the
week before but also he thinks that
uh there is not going to be a decision
on this for four months until the budget
can it really wait that long
yeah you say can it wait that long and
it does feel like the timing all the
stuff is quite important and my kind of
original sense was that richie sunett
wanted to hold back on help until bill's
actually started to bite i mean we had
the wonderful weather this weekend
didn't me i'm sure not many of us have
got a heating on at the minute but
that's going to change isn't it with
those colder months but do you think he
is going to be under pressure to do
something more quickly
well we got the first indication this
week that actually ministers think
they'll have enough information
potentially to act before the summer
recess in other words by the end of july
rather than waiting to august which had
been the original timetable okay uh
thank you very much uh sam enjoy your
castle wherever it is you are i'm not
sure exactly um but thank you very much
for popping up as usual on a sunday
morning thank you
well that is it from sophie ridge on
sunday the take
this morning a big issues for the
government and others to be grappling
with a brexit deal again of course
is the hot issue of next week are the
government prepared to act unilaterally
and what will that mean i feel like
people were skirting around it on the
program this morning but it certainly
will mean
potentially tariffs and at higher prices
if that goes wrong and that breakdown
happens that is it for us this week see
you next sunday
[Music]
you